- Hey, hey out there.
What's going on?
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome
to another another Fed Day,
Aversion of Market Takes.
Thank you so much for being with us.
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me on Fed Day.
Where would you rather be?
And that's even including some
of y'all watching this a little later.
I know not everybody watches with us live.
I appreciate you too.
But those of you watching
with us live right now
4:00 PM Eastern here on Market Takes,
I appreciate you the most.
So I am Dion Rabouin, reporter
for the Wall Street Journal.
This is Market Takes today
we are breaking down,
opening up getting deep inside
the FOMC meeting statement.
Of course the Fed Chairs Press conference
that just ended right
around 45 minutes ago.
We are gonna get into
all that and talk about
what it means in light
of this banking collapse,
this bank run.
This questions about
the systemic fragility
of the US banking system.
You know, I got y'all.
That's what we do here on Market Take.
So of course, like I
said, we'll be talking
through the Fed's rate decision
today, how that aligned
with expectations and why
expectations were what they were.
And we're gonna talk
about what the summary of
economic projection showed.
I think that was pretty important today
and really what the market
is taking away from this.
Obviously, we're gonna talk
about the environment coming
into today's meeting,
how that has been shifted
by these questions about
the banking sector.
And of course check in on the markets.
You know, we always have to do that.
We are gonna also break down
the Powell press conference.
We're gonna talk about
what the chairman said
what he didn't say, what
some of those things mean
and kind of read a
little in between lines.
And then of course, we're gonna
talk about what comes next
because we are always looking forward
even though the data that
we get is backward looking
although today with the Fed statement
and the Fed decision,
that's all happening today.
Markets are reacting today in a major way.
We know that.
So we are gonna get into all of that.
So listen, without any further ado
let's talk about what happened today.
Let's talk about what was
announced, the Fed, the FOMC
the Federal Open Markets
Committee announcing
a 25 basis point increase
in the Fed funds rate
and the effective Fed funds rate.
Wanna throw this chart up here
on your screen just to
give you some context
of what we're looking at.
So where you see
at the right of your
screen, that's where we are.
That line that basically
goes just straight up.
That's what the Fed has
done since March, 2022.
Raising the Fed funds rate sometimes
by 75 basis points, 50 basis points
and today another 25 basis
point increased them.
So they're slowing down
the rate of increases.
And we are still now, but
if you look back there
we're at the highest level
that we've been since 2008.
2008 were when weight started coming
down as a result of the
global financial crisis.
The early days, things
like Lehman Brothers
Bear Stearns had failed
and so you were seeing the Fed start say,
oh we need to start lowering rates.
Well now we're getting them back
up to that level again to try
and fight the inflation that
we have seen in the economy.
Also important to note, as you see there
where we are is unusual rates
had been lower near zero.
As you see rates rolling
along that zero lower bound
as it's called for most of this century,
we are going to start, if
the Fed actually raises rates
to what the level that
they say they plan to
we're gonna get up to the highest level.
We've been since back around 2000, 2001
when we hit that 2001 recession.
It's interesting that
rates tend to get higher
around these recession levels.
And then down when you get lower below
that that's when things
start to get better.
We now could be getting
into some of those economic
worries that folks have had.
So just wanted to put that up there
to illustrate where we are
right now and how that compares
to the environment that we had seen
over the course of the last 20 years.
This is a very unusual environment
and when you look at that Fed,
that effective Fed funds rate chart
you can see just how unusual it is.
So another thing I want to talk
about is the FOMC, the statement today
because the decision to raise
rates by 25 basis points
was accompanied by a statement
and it was also accompanied
by a press conference from the chairman.
Really interesting changes
made to the statement
the Fed usually doesn't like
to change things too much.
They change the date,
they change who voted.
Shout out to our departed
colleague, Lael Brainard
the vice chair of the
Fed now moved on to work
in the government under
President Joe Biden
but she was certainly a
very influential person,
no longer with the Fed now,
working with President
Biden and the government.
But we salute Fed Chair,
our former vice chair Lael Brainard.
Anyway, wanna talk about the statement
though very interesting
pieces because the Fed took
out a statement saying,
job gains have been robust.
They say instead picked
up in recent months
saying meaning essentially
that job growth is even more
than robust it's picked up,
they took out a the reference to inflation
has eased somewhat
and just now it says
inflation remains elevated.
This is the Fed really saying
jobs picking up inflation remains elevated
saying they're more
worried about inflation.
They continue to worry about
the growth of the economy.
That's not the dovish rate hike
that a lot of people
have been talking about.
I think that's why you're seeing some
of what you're seeing in markets.
We will get into that.
Don't worry.
Also, all the references to
Russia's war against Ukraine
which had been
in the second paragraph of
the statement, removed cutout.
Now it starts with the US banking system
is sound and resilient first sentence
in the second paragraph.
Recent developments are likely to result
in tighter credit conditions
for households and businesses
and to weigh on economic
activity, hiring and inflation.
The extent of these effects is uncertain.
The committee remains highly
attentive to inflation risks.
What that tells you is the committee
is now saying all right,
we're not worried as much
about Russia, Ukraine, all that inflation.
Now we're worried about
this banking system
which could urge us to low rates.
I think that may be why as soon
as the statement was released
you saw the stock market jump up
you saw stocks jump higher,
and then as the folks
were reading through this
the algorithms really
reacted immediately to that.
But as real traders, as humans came back
to their computers and
started making moves
you saw a reaction to the
rest of the statement.
Those were the big important
changes in the statement.
So definitely keep your eye on that.
This banking system thing is something
the Fed is keeping watch on,
but that's the second paragraph.
Remember the first
paragraph, the Fed talks
about inflation as job
growth has picked up
and inflation remains
elevated, not has he somewhat.
We're taking that out.
Inflation remains elevated.
That's big and that's a big piece
of why I think the market's
doing what it's doing.
Let's also talk about
how the Fed's balance sheet has changed
and what's been happening
because as a result of this banking issue
I don't wanna call it a
banking crisis or a bank run
but as a result of some
of these issues with the
banks, the Fed has made moves.
So on the one hand they're saying, okay
we're watching this.
On the other hand, I wanna
throw something up here
on your screen just to show
you some of the actions
that the Fed has been taking
because a lot of this is about words,
but it's also about actions.
And so just want to put this chart up here
at the Fed's balance sheet on your screen.
Now what you see is
just that parabolic rise
from 2020 Fed's balance sheet
just goes up and up and up.
That's what we, they called QE
or what I guess we in the
media called QE Infinity
where the Fed said we will buy
as many bonds as necessary.
They ratcheted that
balance sheet up and up
and up and up to levels that
had never reached before
had never even been close to before,
we're always in unprecedented territory.
And you got to the balance
sheet being about $9 trillion
as in the Fed had bought $9 trillion worth
of bonds and other things,
some of 'em being bonds
from junk rated companies,
some being big companies
like Apple, Verizon, things like that.
The Fed was basically
buying anything could get
its hands on and you saw
that rise all the way
up to about $9 trillion on
the Fed's balance sheet.
That was money they were pumping
out in the economy by buying these bonds.
And then you see that number that kind of,
it starts to come down there
and then at the very
right edge of your screen
you see that big tick up,
that just straight line.
That was last week and that's what the Fed
did in response to this banking issue.
That's almost $300 billion.
The Fed added to its balance
sheet and that is huge.
Now, that's more than the week
after Lehman Brothers
collapsed in October, 2008.
Even when accounting for inflation.
So even when you factor in inflation,
the Fed did more last week
than they did after
Lehman Brothers collapsed.
Even though we're talking
about what they're saying is a
far less worrisome situation.
So keep that in mind now.
I just wanted to throw that up there
to illustrate just how
big and how substantial
the Fed's response to that banking crisis.
The issues with Silicon Valley Bank,
Signature Bank and others.
This worries about First Republic
and all those things had been,
the Fed was clearly worried.
They injected a lot of
money into the system.
That's a lot of money that goes
out into the economy,
at least hypothetically
when the Fed's doing all
of these things adding
to its balance sheet,
they say, we're doing this
because we're trying to
support and uplift the economy.
Well, as they're trying
to reign in the economy
raise rates to kind of lower inflation
they also just pumped about $300 billion
which is kind of doing the opposite
of what they had talked about.
Now, Fed chair, Jerome Powell was asked
about this during the press conference.
He kinda said, oh, this is different.
But listen, they're buying bonds
they're pumping money into the economy.
They're pushing money
into the banking system
which is exactly what
they said they were doing
to help offset some of the issues
from the economic crisis at 2008, in 2020
and in the years that followed that
when you see that balance
sheet just go up and up and up.
So this is important to watch out for.
Now, let's talk about the Fed's summary
of economic projections or
how the Fed sees the economy.
What I want to throw up here
is the so-called dot plot.
These are FOMC members
quote unquote assessments of the economy.
And just wanna put this up on your screen.
This is the December
dot plot of FOMC members
and as you can see there,
it's right around 5.1%.
There wasn't a big change from December
which is about three months ago
their last meeting when they
did the dot plot to today.
But you see numbers
hovering around for 2023
expecting rates to be about 5.1%
a few lower, a more than a few higher.
But all in all, the expectation
is 5.1 points, 5.1%.
Now let's throw
up the March summary of
economic projections.
The dot plot, this is March now,
you see it's very similar
but a little different
in that you see there are
a couple dots moved higher,
no one's moved lower.
There's in fact less dots you see there
under that 5% level than
there were in December, right?
There's just that one dot under 5%.
Everyone expects rates to be at least 5%.
A couple people have
raised their expectations
above five and a half percent
and now there's even one,
there's that one more dot even higher
almost at that 6% level.
So wanna put that up just to illustrate
that this was not a
hike where the Fed said,
okay we're hiking 'cause we have to
but we think really
things are gonna go easy
and smooth as we move
forward in the future.
No, no, no.
The Fed is saying we still
think we have to do more
and that has a lot to do
with the data that we've
seen and that has a lot to do
with the environment we saw
coming into this report.
So let's talk about that.
The environment we saw
coming into today's meeting
and to today's decision to
raise rates by 25 basis points
'cause we know why they did that.
First of all, CPI and PPI
that's a consumer price index
and a producer price index.
What individuals you and I are paying
when we go to the store
and what businesses are
paying for their goods.
Those have been coming
down consistently declining
for about the past six,
seven, eight months now.
We've seen those decline
and we've seen also the
outsized role of shelter
AKA housing, aka rent
prices and home prices.
That's been holding it up even though
the fed's real-time indicators have shown
that that's declining.
Fed Chair Powell mentioned
that today in the press conference.
He says, we know that new
leases are being signed
at the pace of inflation
in leases and in rent is coming down.
We've seen that even though
in CPI and in PPI, it's
keeping, it's staying elevated.
Remember if you watch Market Takes
when we did CPI at our last
this was last week on I
believe the 15th of March.
We talked about the outsized role
that shelter AKA housing was playing.
And we know that this
is a lagging indicator.
It takes a long time
for this to get factored into the reports.
And so when you're seeing
shelter holding up CPI,
well you can assume, and
it's probably safe to assume
that CPI is actually lower
than what we're seeing
in some of those numbers
and PPI is lower than what we're seeing
even though it plays a much smaller part.
So with CPI being lower in inflation
for consumers overall being
lower, that's good news for Fed.
It says that they can slow down.
We also have seen that over the course
of this time services
inflation has been picking
up while goods inflation
which drove a big part of the increase
in inflation over the
past couple years or so.
As we've been in this pandemic environment
or post pandemic environment.
Goods prices have been picking up, well,
they've come down considerably,
but now services prices are coming up
as in what you pay when
you go to the doctor
what you're paying when you're going out
to the bar restaurants,
when you go see a specialist
for some medicine or when you
just go to the amusement park.
All those things are
services rather than goods.
Those are things that you buy on Amazon
or when you go to the store,
those prices are rising
even while goods prices are declining.
And that's what the
Fed is concerned about.
Fed chair, Jerome Powell
spotlighted that today.
One thing to worry about
with that as well as
been the jobs reports,
jobs have been growing at a very fast pace
and we have not seen the
sort of moderation or decline
in pickup and jobs growth
that the Fed wants to see.
The Fed wants to see.
It is said in its summary
of economic projections
it expects unemployment to rise about 1%.
That means millions of
people lose their jobs.
They also wanna see fewer job openings.
And what we saw in the JOLTS report,
the Job Opening and Labor Turnover Survey
was there have been
fewer job openings added
as in people are posting
fewer jobs looking
for employees than they had previously.
That has come down a
little bit but not a lot
and we're still seeing
that at a very high rate.
So all those things support
kind of the Fed moving
taking its foot off the brake
and sort of slowing down
doing a little bit less.
On the other side of that, we
do have the China reopening.
We have that services increase
in prices that we've seen
and that affects a lot more of the economy
because the US is a mostly
service-based economies economy
excuse me, unlike other
places like Germany, China
et cetera, that are still
based on exporting goods.
You've got also with China
reopening, you've got a number
of other countries
seeing inflation pick up.
France inflation or
inflation in France rose
to 6.2% in February up from January.
Inflation in Japan rose to
4.4% up from in January.
In the UK, inflation
is still double digits
and the euros on inflation
fell just a little bit
from 8.6 to 8.5%.
What's that telling us?
That saying that all over
the world, inflation is still
either picking up or coming
down just a little bit
and that impacts us because
this is a global economy.
No economy exists in a vacuum.
Everything happens with
relation to other economies.
All those things are worrisome.
Also, we saw those existing home sales,
the report that came out earlier this week
showed existing home sales up 14.5%.
That's the thing the fed's policy
can have the most direct
impact on and it's showing
that existing home sales spiked up
after coming down consistently
for a number of months.
Housing starts also up by about 10%.
This shows the Fed is not slowing demand.
That's gotta be something
they're worried about
and that could be why we saw
what I think is a hawkish rate
hike this month from the Fed.
So keep that in mind.
On the other side of that also, of course,
oil and gas prices have been coming lower,
natural gas has been just
jumping off a cliff price wise.
And that means
that you're seeing different
forces kind of converging
and we're gonna see which one breaks out.
Now, inflation has
consistently moved lower
in recent months, but we've also seen
this banking crisis that could be evidence
that things are breaking
within the economy and the
Fed needs to slow down.
I'm seeing a lot of folks,
economists, market watchers
et cetera in my inbox saying,
"Dion, the Fed is making a mistake.
They need to slow down, they
need to stop raising rates
they need to reevaluate
what they're doing."
That's all because, and not all
because actually I should say
that case has been increased
or you know folks have pointed
to this and said this is evidence
that the Fed needs to slow down and stop
because the problems in banking
are gonna hurt businesses
especially small and mid-size
businesses that rely on banks.
These big companies, they go out
in the markets and they
can borrow money there
but these small and medium
businesses that need banks,
banks are gonna pull back because of this.
There's a lot of worry
about what banks are doing
and not going out and lending
and that's gonna hurt businesses,
that's gonna hurt mom and pop
and that's gonna hit people
right in their pocketbooks.
Really quickly, wanna check
in on the markets real fast?
We've got the Dow and the
S and P and the Nasdaq
all down significantly down about 1.6%.
Each index is hovering
right around that level.
We saw a huge nose dive in stock prices
and I think that's because
of this hawkishness
that we're seeing from the Fed.
Fed saying they can basically
they're not prepared to back
off what they were doing.
The market could be
thinking one of two things.
One could be
that the Fed isn't seeing
the force for the trees
that they're not understanding
what's happening here
in the market and that
they're making a huge mistake.
The other possibility
is that they see, okay
the Fed is determined
to get inflation down.
And so we are seeing
these moves and inflation
the ones we talked about, price
is moving higher on services
things like job increases continuing
and they've seen, okay
the Fed is gonna get back
to doing what it was doing
when we were worried.
Now it's time to sell stocks,
it's time to get outta risk,
it's time to move things lower
because the Fed is gonna be back
on its horse making moves, taking action.
And that's not gonna be good for stocks.
It could be either one of those.
We're seeing the same
move in the bond market.
You're seeing bond prices move higher
which means those yields
are falling lower.
Really across the board,
the six month is up about
five basis points today
in price, down about five basis
points, excuse me, in yield.
The 10 year is down about
14 basis points in yield.
These are some pretty
significant moves five year
in the three year down
about 23 basis points in
terms of the yield there.
Also, let's check out crude futures,
I think is really interesting.
Brent crude is down about 1%.
WTI is up about half percent.
Very interesting, but gold
and silver are up huge.
That shows you that the market
is worried about recession.
We're seeing gold up
about 1.8%, almost 2%,
silver up almost 3%.
Those are generally
worries about recession
and that's what we could be
seeing here from the market.
Also, very important, don't
wanna skip out currencies.
The Euro is up big on the dollar
but that movie has come
down significantly.
If the dollar and the Euro
ended about parody today
or the dollar ends up rising,
that could be a significant notification
to the rest of the market
that there are real
worries about recession
and about the fate and about the path
for growth moving forward.
All right, listen, we were
gonna talk a little bit
about the Powell Press
conference, but I think I talked
about that Fed chair,
Jerome Powell highlighted
again super core inflation,
that's that services ex housings
or core services, ex housing
really a particular
measure that's still rising
and the Fed has said, our
eyes are still on that
and I think that was a
signal to the market.
Things haven't changed
the Fed is still doing what it's doing.
Maybe we shouldn't have gotten all excited
over these past few days.
What comes next?
Well, we've got new home sales tomorrow.
This existing home sales report was bad
if you're worried about inflation
because it shows that
people are not deterred
by mortgage rates where
they are single family
and multifamily homes picked
up in this last report.
That report was all bad for inflation.
This next report, new home sales
that's out tomorrow on Thursday.
That's gonna give you
a big signal on whether
or not the Fed's rate
hikes are having an impact
on the overall housing market.
Maybe new home sales turn down
existing home sales are about
85 to 90% of the market.
So that was the big report.
But new home sales would kind
of either bring that home
or refute that 'cause we also
saw it with housing starts.
Also, the Fed discount window
borrowing numbers are out tomorrow.
We're gonna get an update on that.
That's where we saw this big
almost $300 billion
increase from last week.
We checked that on Thursday,
it's coming out tomorrow.
Be sure and check that out.
That's gonna tell you how much more banks
are taking advantage of the Fed's money.
Also, flash PMIs on
manufacturing services out Friday
the latest update on the economy
and how businesses see it.
And of course next week
we'll have pending home sales
on Wednesday, University of
Michigan, consumer sentiment
on Friday and New York Fed
President John Williams
will talk about how
he's seeing the economy.
He's a very close confidant
of Fed chair, Jerome Powell.
And we know that when
John Williams is talking,
he's speaking what the Fed is thinking.
Very important, check
out what he's saying.
Listen, we went a little long
today here on Market Takes
but those of y'all that are stuck with me
that are still with me here,
I appreciate you being here.
I know you could have
tuned out at any time,
gone anywhere else in the world
but you're stuck here with
me and I appreciate that.
Look, thanks for being with
us so much on Market Takes
and we will see you next time.